en un discurso ante el parlamento la
canciller alemana angela merkel defendió
este jueves las restricciones acordadas
entre el gobierno federal y las
autoridades regionales y que estarán
vigentes en la época navideña y que
tienen además el doble objetivo de por
un lado ayudar a que se reduzcan aún más
las nuevas infecciones y por otro lado
permitir que los alemanes puedan de
alguna manera celebrar la navidad en
familia la principal decisión que se
tomó fue la de alargar el llamado lock
down o parcial que originalmente estaba
previsto hasta el 30 de noviembre pero
ahora continuará hasta al menos el 20 de
diciembre y por el cual los bares los
restaurantes y los museos deberán
continuar cerrados también se acordó que
durante los días de la navidad entre el
23 de diciembre el primero de enero los
alemanes podrán reunirse en familia
máximo 10 personas sin contar niños todo
esto ocurre en momentos en que las
autoridades alemanas explicaron que el
crecimiento exponencial pudo detenerse
de hecho angela merkel explicó en el
parlamento
que los contactos se redujeron en las
últimas semanas en un 40% pero también
en momentos en que alemania está
preocupado aún por el alto número de
infecciones y sobre todo por el alto
número de muertes en los últimos ocho
días laborales alemania registró más de
200 muertes cada día